i don't believe any of the coverage of
megan has
anything to do with her race nothing
absolutely nothing it's a narrative that
she has
created and it's a narrative that a lot
of people sadly create now
in order to try and make them um
immune from criticism hey francis do you
want to keep your online activity
private yes i don't want anyone to know
i secretly watch
bbc comedy embarrassing that's why you
need
surf shark vpn how can shark serve shut
up
surfshark is a virtual private network
available as an
easy to use app and browser extension
that lets you place your laptop
or phone anywhere in the world allowing
you to access the internet as if you
were in another country
this means that i can access a whole
host of websites
that i wouldn't be able to access in the
uk not only that
you can protect your online identity by
masking your true ip address
with surfshark you can protect yourself
from data theft
tracking surveillance and commercial
targeting and it's great value for money
because
one surfshark account can be used on
multiple devices
so you can access problematic content
wherever you are and by problematic
content we do mean trigonometry click
the link below
and use our code trigonometry to get
83 percent off plus three extra months
for free
surf shark also offers a 30-day
money-back guarantee
so there's no risk to trying it out for
yourself click the link below
and use our code trigonometry to get
83 off plus three extra months for free
[Music]
look we've we've done the lockdown
covered doom and gloom let's talk about
something more light-hearted because
you're a big fan of the celeb gosh you
love a bit of the royals as well
megan and harry and this please forgive
me for what will
sound quite rightly as a slightly snobby
question
really yeah from me it's very unusual
but
why why do people care about that sort
of stuff because you
you love it and you're very good at
covering it and when i'm on your show
with we talk about it and there's always
a
you know with with harry and megan
there's there's a bit of a political
angle which we can talk about in a sec
well why do people care about this sort
of stuff more generally
well it's interesting because you say i
care and i obviously do care to a degree
i i would say that the last
couple of years has changed where i'm at
though because obviously i was very
in a celebrity focused world and i think
a lot of people probably over the course
of the pandemic
have reconsidered what's important and
what we care about but obviously
as a culture we care significantly about
celebrities
and about the royal family and i don't
think there's anything wrong
or shameful about that and actually you
know
one thing that i want to do with my show
on gb news and it's something that i
always would do
at the sun as well is acknowledge that
we
can cover lots of different news and
you don't demean something by also
covering something that actually people
are talking about because what is news
what is news news is what people are
talking about so
you know the kardashians ending their e
reality show is news you know that is
big news they have
changed pop culture they have changed
the way that we consume social media
they've genuinely changed the way a
generation behaves
so them ending that show to me is really
significant news
uh the royal family obviously you're
completely right they take on a
different
dimension because everything they do is
history
it's history you know and it will be
written about
for decades and centuries to come
because of the the cultural structure we
have in this country
and obviously it's been an absolutely
torrid and unprecedented time the most
unprecedented time
for the royal family since the death of
princess diana in 1997 and
certainly for me as a teenager when
princess diana died i was i was 14. i
mean
you know there are two news stories that
i feel like define
my teenage years and obviously one is 9
11.
and the other is the death of princess
diana you know it was such a moment for
this
country and such a moment in culture as
well and
absolutely changed culture it changed uh
our relationship with celebrities and
and the royals but also
changed how we are
as brits because her death
brought out a whole other
sort of idea of of expressing
public emotion and feelings and i think
if anything it was sort of the end of
the british stiff upper lip
and then of course you have harry and
megan
and what they represent i think
is the woke culture coming to the royal
family
and my god it has been a culture clash
like like none other it's interesting
that you say that for me i think the
reason that people latched on to it so
much
is because it represented the
generational divide
you have the divide of you know the
queen philip duty
country etc etc you put your role before
yourself
and then you have the woke which is you
know it's about my feelings it's about
how i see the world it's about
protecting myself keeping myself safe
and the two just they just don't fit do
they no of course not
of course not and megan was a
celebrity i mean not a huge celebrity
but she was a c-list actress but the
point is
she understood the power of the media
she understood the power of social media
she absolutely understood the power of
celebrity
and she came in and blew it up
she she blew it up she didn't care about
royal tradition
i she said all of the right things at
the start but her behavior behind the
scenes and of course i was covering it
very very closely and it was a
fascinating period for me because
obviously i'd been
when megan entered the royal family i'd
just been editing the bizarre column
which is the big celebrity showbiz
column at the sun
and i'd left that and megan entered and
it was this
fusion between royalty and celebrity so
it was
i was sort of perfectly placed really
because i knew
megan's story and i knew people who knew
megan and i knew what sort of person she
was and i knew how fame-hungry she was
and i
knew all about her and to see her enter
the royal family in the royal family
just
literally unable to cope was just
fascinating it was fascinating and
you know i broke story after story about
it
and people cared you know people cared
and obviously it culminated in me
uh breaking the story of mexic
and you know she
they released their statement announcing
they were leaving the royal family about
you know eight hours after i'd broken
the story so it was it was a crazy
period
and then so we're talking about the
royal family we're talking about mexic
we're also talking about the escapades
of prince andrew
are we seeing the slow death of the
royal family because i think for myself
once the queen dies that's a major
question we're going to ask ourselves
as a nation what is what is the purpose
of this family yeah guys we're going to
cheer up this episode after 40 minutes
of lockdown by talking about the
sovereign dying
there we go no i really don't think
we're witnessing the death of the royal
family but i do think the royal family
is in crisis
i i don't think it's an existential
crisis but i think it's a crisis
and it's a big crisis and the
publication of prince harry's book next
year
is a bomb that is about to go off and
everyone knows it prince charles knows
it prince william knows it camilla knows
it
and it's going to be very significant
it's going to be very very significant
and i don't think he could bring the
royal family down but he could do more
damage to the royal family is he going
to name the royal racist
what's he going to say about his
relationship with camilla what's he
going to say about his dad
and it's obviously very different to the
situation with princess diana because
princess diana wanted to bring her
husband down and she wanted to bring
camilla down
but she didn't want to bring the world
family down in the institution down
and i sent something quite different
with harry
and megan there's something quite
republican
about their actions and
that's really quite disturbing because
what
the royal family is they have no idea
what's coming
they have no way to control this couple
and prince harry knows everything and i
don't get the sense
that he wants to hold stuff back in this
book i i mean i know i've obviously
reported on
them very closely over the past couple
of years my expectation
is that um they'll be very careful not
to say anything that could look
offensive to the queen or prince philip
but outside of that i think um it's game
on
gloves are off gloves so you you talk
about knowing
meg people who know megan and being
familiar with so
what's the dynamics there like because
people talk about
she's come in and she's kind of taken
him to a different place mentally
or sort of almost taken advantage that
like what what's the dynamics there in
your opinion
well look i've always said i don't
believe you can blame megan
you know harry's the prince isn't he
harry's the prince he's the one that had
all of the power i don't think you can
blame megan
she's had a huge influence on him she's
clearly a very manipulative
human being and uh she's
got him and i think look i
i judge people a bit i know everyone's
situation is different
but i do judge people a bit based on
who's in their life from their childhood
both in terms of family and and friends
and and school friends and i know in my
life so i just think about me you know
my family and my friends from school are
everything to me because
they know me better than anyone else and
my goodness they would be the first
people i would have at my wedding at any
cost
you know and megan had her mum she had
her mum
and every other person who was with her
at that wedding were friends that she
had made
post becoming famous in suits you know
so
the pr for burberry and the membership
manager at soho house you know that's
that's a very particular type of human
being isn't it
and you know i've got to know megan's
sister samantha
and she's had a lot of flack but i got
to know her very early on
and what i would say is that everything
that samantha was saying and
at the time remember she was just
accused of being a troll you know but
everything that samantha warned has
turned out to be true
you know don't let her in harry she's
going to tear you away from your own
family
and that's what's happened that's what's
happened you know harry doesn't have a
connection with his own family now apart
from his grandmother really
and megan doesn't have a connection with
her own family apart from her mother so
i mean it's a fascinating dynamic it's a
fascinating story
at the end of the day they can do what
they want now
but why do they still have
hrh titles i don't get that i just
that's what i don't get why does megan
release a book
and say megan the duchess of sussex you
know if she
meant what she says about
not caring about the royal family
wanting to be her own person
wanting to be a modern feminist then
surely it should be megan markle
that's what i don't get that they
everything they do
trades off the royal family it's a very
weird dichotomy
do you think that the criticism of megan
was was based in racism
and because there's a lot of people go
look right you can say what you like
about megan
she hasn't done anything illegal and
then you look at prince
you know allegedly with his best mate
epstein flying around the world
why is he not receiving more criticism
well i
i have very strong feelings on this uh
so let me take
the sort of two things so i'll tackle
andrew and then the racism if that's
okay so
prince andrew the media and i get it all
the time people say to me
why are you not covering andrew as much
as megan it's like
well number one i have and number two
without
the media uh specifically my old
newspaper the news of the world
which spent weeks and weeks exposing
prince andrew's relationship
with jeffrey epstein without the media
there would be
absolutely no knowledge of what prince
andrew did with jeffrey epstein nothing
every single revelation about prince
andrew has been entirely driven by
british newspapers so the news of the
world the mail on sunday
uh the sun primarily and for a long time
the establishment and the royal family
just wanted to ignore that story
they just wanted it to go away there was
no desire to bring down prince andrew
it was only reporting from british
newspapers
that exposed the story in the first
place and then of course it was the
catastrophic car crash interview
by the bbc with prince andrew that
actually forced the queen's hand and
finally got him sacked from the royal
family so
this idea that the british media has
somehow tried to protect prince andrew
it's just
laughably untrue and you can probably
tell it makes me really angry because
it's a narrative that's used by megan
supporters
and it's just so wrong uh the second
point on the racism
i'm also really passionate about because
i covered that wedding
and you know i was there at windsor
and i've never seen other than the
uh 2012 olympics i've
genuinely never seen the country
more united or happy or more celebratory
oh my god we got behind megan the
british public loved this woman we
totally embraced the idea of a
multicultural royal family
the whole country stopped that day for
their wedding
there were street parties you know i i
remember going to one after the wedding
everyone was on cloud nine the
newspapers
ran page after page after page about how
incredible megan was about the potential
impact
that she would have on the royal family
you know megan
never wanted it to work she never wanted
it to work
and she always was trying to construct a
narrative
of racist coverage of her and i find it
craven
and weird and sad because it doesn't
exist you know
literally people point to one headline
about avocados
and one headline that referenced that
movie what is it you know
um compton you know um straight out of
compton
referring to the fact that she was from
a particular area and actually if you go
and read that article i think it was by
rachel johnson you know boris johnson's
sister it was actually a broadly
positive article so
i'm sorry find me the racist coverage it
doesn't exist it's a narrative
created by harry and megan it's
manipulative
uh because remember i mean and i'm not
saying this is
necessarily right but a huge amount of
negative press
about kate middleton i remember it yeah
you know this is the point i always
see katie yeah well i remember yeah that
and also i
can't remember and i don't want to get
it wrong because of the libel laws that
you talked about but some
tabloid journalist on question time
talking about coverage of her and sort
of this is
this is way back when but it was he said
literally and i remember this because
even i was slightly like taken aback and
shocked you went
look all she needs to do right is go out
there show a bit of leg
and and i was like she was getting
slammed pretty hard
just for like trying to have some
semblance of a private life yeah and
there's his there's a history of this
in terms of female outsider females
entering the royal family
princess steiner i mean hardly an
outsider but but you know what i'm
saying she wasn't a member of the royal
family uh sarah ferguson fergie coverage
of her
absolutely brutal duchess of pork you
know
negative headline after negative
headline sophie wessex you know
exposed by the news of the world and a
sting by the fake shake
all of these princesses that enter the
royal family got bad coverage so
look i'm not defending that maybe we
need to have a broader look about how we
treat females entering the royal family
as a society but to claim
that it's racism because the same thing
happened to megan
is just wrong and actually you know
being there reporting it for the whole
time
it took a long time before any negative
reporting happened
about megan i probably was one of the
journalists
that started it but it was based on her
behavior so i broke
and it was very difficult to do at the
time because all of the coverage of
megan had been positive this is a thing
but i broke um a story and it became
known as
tiara gate and it might look small in
the scheme of things now but at the time
it was very significant
because i was the first person to break
that basically the queen
had warned harry about
megan's behavior and it had all come
from this bust up before the wedding
about megan wanting to wear a particular
tiara which the queen didn't want to
lend her which feels very
royal and ridiculous doesn't it but
within that story
i also revealed that kate and megan
had fallen out over the way that megan
was speaking to
staff at kensington palace and we now
know
there were bullying claims against her
on the record to the hr team at the
royal family i mean the point that i'm
making is
these are not stories constructed by the
media you know the media was reporting
what was going on behind the scenes
and it actually took many many months
for us to uncover what was going on
and i think there's a lot that was going
on that still
hasn't been reported on because the
bar that you have to reach to report
on the goings-on behind the scenes of
the royal family is very high
you know it's very high because you're
under a lot of pressure as a journalist
if you get anything wrong connected to
the royal family so yeah so
that's a very long-winded way of saying
i don't believe any of the coverage
of megan has anything to do with her
race
nothing absolutely nothing it's a
narrative that she
has created and it's a narrative that a
lot of people sadly create now
in order to try and make them um
immune from criticism which i think is
quite dangerous is it not
it is very very very dangerous because
it would be like me saying
you can't criticize me because i'm gay
because if you criticize me it must be
homophobic
that's literally where megan is at but
it's a tool of choice as we now know for
quite a lot of people
and what's interesting to me i am not
someone who's paid
almost any attention to to this stuff
but
i mean let's start with the fact i am
darker than meghan markle
right so the idea that people
you know i remember that wedding and i
actually remember thinking this is a bit
over the top here
to be honest how we were just like
obsessing about this wedding and blah
blah blah
it looked to me like she got pretty good
coverage but quite a few people
actually you know lost jobs or or got
into trouble
by making the coin comments that you've
just made and i don't think you will
and now but there was a moment in time
where i think pierce morgan go and god
knows i disagree with pierce morgan and
a lot of stuff but
he got into a lot of trouble in my view
unfairly lawrence fox got into a lot of
trouble for again making the same point
like why why was there this just desire
to tear down anyone who who made the
point that you just made well yeah i
think because the narrative became that
if you were criticizing meghan markle
you were racist
and pears accused her of lying
in the oprah interview and it was
particularly
hot and heightened because itv had
become a big proponent of mental health
which is very ironic given uh the way
that they treat people but anyway that's
a whole other story but that become a
big public proponent of mental health
and um a lawyer just breathed out of
relief mitch
another time but um but
you know it's provable that
megan told a number of lies during the
oprah interview it's provable
and pairs lost his job or he he left
because he refused to apologize after
megan directly complained we believe to
the chief executive of itv
and you know what do we live in a world
where
because you're a princess and because
you're a mixed race princess and because
you claim you've suffered from mental
health issues we believe
anything you say i mean
isn't the job of journalists to
expose public figures telling fibs and
and porcupines no no
not anymore not anymore dan and on that
wonderfully upbeat note thank you so
much for coming on the show
we're going to be asking some locals
questions but
our last question is always what's the
one thing we're not talking about
but we really should be well i think
this this is probably quite a curveball
based on everything we've been talking
about uh
during the show because it's not related
to any of it but i think it is
about tech addiction i'm absolutely
convinced
it's going to become one of the most
important stories
over the next 20 years i think
i'm addicted to my phone right in a way
that is genuinely quite scary
and i think for young people that have
grown up literally
from two years old
not doing anything other than touching
technology
from the moment they they wake up to the
moment they go to bed
there's going to be a whole load of
mental health and societal challenges
around that and we just don't talk about
it do we but
everything now that we need in our life
is contained
very often in a phone and it's breaking
down
lots of social interaction in society
it's causing lots of relationship
difficulties and
yeah i think tech addiction is something
that i mean you you see
companies like apple sort of are aware
that this could be
going to become a big issue which is why
they've introduced things like
screen time where they tell you how much
time you've spent on your phone but i
see
it it doesn't stop me doing it you know
just because i know i'm addicted it
doesn't mean i'm not addicted
do you see what i mean and i think it's
going to become
a huge issue for the big tech companies
and also social
media as well because all of them play
and play into each other so how do we
still use technology and harness the
brilliance of technology
without losing the importance of human
interaction
and and what that brings us all and
i think especially with the pandemic and
having people especially young people
locked up at home for the past two years
i think
uh the ramifications from it huge and i
think it's going to be a big story to
come but at the moment it's just not
being covered
dan thank you so much for coming on the
show ironically if people want to find
you online where would be the best place
uh probably by my social media so i'm at
dan wilson on
twitter and facebook and instagram and
of course your gb news show remind
people where
yeah and tv news tonight live uh is on 9
00 pm until midnight
monday to thursday of course constantine
you're with me every thursday night so
if you're a fan of trigonometry and you
want a bit
extra dose of constantine you've got to
join us on thursday and gb news you can
download the app wherever you are in the
world as well so you don't even have to
be in the uk
and it's free fantastic dan thanks so
much for coming on
and thank you for watching at home and
listening at home we will see you very
soon with another brilliant episode like
this one
or a raw show all of them go out 7pm uk
time which is 2pm eastern
take care and see you soon see you soon
guys
we hope you've enjoyed this incredible
interview remember to subscribe
and hit the bell button so that you
never miss another fantastic episode
and if you believe that the work we do
here at trigonometry is important
support us by joining our locals
community using
the link below